c'est un travail minutieux que fabienne
réalise avec dextérité dans cette
entreprise l'humain est un atout de
taille pour les produits il est
difficile de positionner par exemple ce
par quoi d' ici sur l'angle de la mousse
une machine ne pourrait pas le faire en
tant que tel ça serait difficile donc
fabienne bien positionner parfaitement
correctement sur la mousse même du côté
de la couture le savoir faire des
petites mains est essentielle mireille
est couturière depuis 38 ans dans cet
atelier
c'est avec passion qu'elle transmet son
métier on fait tout photo est
entièrement tout savoir
tous les morceaux entre les mails et
suivant les tissus aussi différents cuir
ou les tissus ne travaillent pas tous de
la même année
l'entreprise embauche très rarement en
intérim au contrat de courte durée pour
laisser cette transmission s'effectue
sur le long terme
ébénisterie teinte montage finition seul
le métal et les moteurs sont
sous-traités les machines n'ont pas
totalement disparu
mais le travail manuel est privilégiée
d'abord c'est pas dit non c'est vous
contraire des grands minces et des gens
qui ont une compétence fabuleuse et qui
savent d'une part réaliser des produits
et surtout ça permet d'avoir en continu
une personnalisation importantes
c'est-à-dire de s'adapter au mieux aux
désirs de nos clients et d'autre part
d'avoir un contrôle qualité permanent
sur les produits choses qui ne seraient
pas possibles soit si nous souhaitions
soit si cet effet mécaniquement cette
entreprise de fauteuils de relaxation a
même lancé une innovation celle du
fauteuil zéro gravité
elle emploie 37 salariés et dispose de
ses propres magasins et showroom